we I can't stop playing this game I've
been left my house in three days I told
you I'm still sick
I told me bros to join this server and
feed and Gary Oh Oh see how that goes
but obviously we're gonna get to number
one and Garrett will roll the world
I don't see a single bro yet I don't
know about this theory anymore man oh
you just [ __ ] up now didn't yet you
[ __ ] up now hey got you I got you
Oh God Sweden [ __ ] you Sweden I mean I
love you Sweden yeah we're never alone
whose kid is now [ __ ] but you can
expect this [ __ ] ooh
Oh Netherlands I'm coming for your sweet
ass
Oh God are you done [ __ ] up now -
never [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I bought
I bought [ __ ] you Mars [ __ ] you Mars how
is he big enough [ __ ] this game [ __ ]
everyone I hate it
[ __ ] you friends [ __ ] you [ __ ] off I'm
the best player in the world one day
I'll go MLG thank you whoever that was
appreciate it
like the other day we played there was
like a bar no no no [ __ ] you then I love
Paris yay
we're both blue oh god no yeah why oh
god this could be bad Thank You Edgar
well that guy's same feed again some dog
treats for Edgar oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god
[ __ ] you doggie [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god oh
god oh oh oh what you gonna do now [ __ ]
hey miss thank you thanks
with this feeding area yes that make me
huge oh I want sanic sass pls sanic let
me feast on you sanic come on sanic
thank you I'm fine I'm fine
look at this [ __ ] okay maybe not I'm fun
maybe I'm not fine how about that have
you thought about that we're kind of
stuck in the Medicare spewed thank you
thank you
feed my doggie this is so ridiculous
well it looks like you don't [ __ ] up
now didn't ya hey god damn we're second
oh my god that's amazing
that was you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
oh I'm gonna [ __ ] murder you and your
children
man this is so [ __ ] exhilarating I
[ __ ] love a
you can't eat him no please don't please
don't please please stop you what
[ __ ] for parents you present really
started to drop it I love it
hey Edgar right between my titties Thank
You breasts bless ya
nice going Edgar nice going
proud of you he's [ __ ] trapped here
isn't he
I wonder if I can eat him oh hello I'll
take a look
no no what the [ __ ] happened why my son
my heart see are you so intense it's
ridiculous
[ __ ] sake mailman what do i do oh my
god no please please for the love of God
oh oh okay food friend hey you guys haha
[ __ ] your breath so much this is [ __ ]
amazing oh [ __ ]
you guys better [ __ ] hurry up because
[ __ ] Portugal is coming to suck my
dick no no careful Maya holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] man we need to [ __ ] at Portugal up
Maya
why are you nibbling on my titties Maya
I don't like this the [ __ ] are you doing
Maya Maya Maya Maya Maya Maya [ __ ] are
you doing Maya well that was [ __ ]
worth it wasn't it [ __ ] you Maya